is a man just a couple of weeks removed
from having 200 yards receiving in
London he is Los Angeles Rams wide
receiver and a man who's on two of my
three fantasy teams no pressure Cooper
Cup how are you Cooper okay how was that
London trip for you pretty good huh oh
come on now
I'm not talking about the W I'm talking
about all those yards you-you-you left
the impression with the Brits that this
is something that happens all the time
now we'll just take the W and you know
be happy okay so there is there really
is no I in Cooper or Cup it's basically
what you're saying right now I mean my
English teacher is pretty good okay very
good
Cooper Cup taking on again a Ravens
defense you are I have a handful coming
your way what have you seen on film
already of this Ravens defense Cooper
Cup the highest listing teams no League
so just being ready and prepared for
that and you know playmakers across the
board up front gushers some big guys in
the middle
I thought the factors play really well
obviously they got so many deep music
and plays and you see them playing you
know a lot of nickels don't even dollar
packages and thinking all the guys on
the field playing man coverage
Langdon just played it off soon so you
know really presented a challenge for us
and we're really excited and pleased
I imagine Marcus Peters is someone you
used to go against in practice said it
would that be a yes okay so he's gonna
bring a nice bowl of gumbo to use his
phrase to this game this year I think
three pick sixes on the year something
like that and really just a ball hog
just you have to respect that about
Marcus and you know obviously we've
known from being here but really I feel
go up against something a real game time
setting do you
Marcus Peters may have a similar
approach to not sharing with his current
teammates about his former teammates
that Eric Weddle appears to have with
you Cooper
you know I'm not sure I'm not you know
I'm I would I would think Marcus would
probably you know he said whatever it
takes to win that standpoint and you
know uh you know I have a ton of respect
for the Weddell you know just being able
I think he will talk about ball he loves
saw football so right we talk ball all
the time you know that's not gonna
change this week no I know but he says
he is he truly not coughing everything
up that he knows about the the Ravens to
the team right now okay very good
and then on this football front this is
fascinating to me that playing Lamar
Jackson in the in on the scout team
right now is a teammate of yours named
John Walford who left Wall Street to
play for the Jets and then the AAF
before winding up on your team who tell
me what you know about and/or let folks
know a little bit more about John who's
playing Lamar Jackson against your
defense and scout maybe Drew Brees okay
you know he can swing the rock very very
athletic quarterback that uh you know I
think his he is a very quick trigger in
terms you don't get the ball out and
really a good dude as well so very
intelligent you know makes plays and no
I think you know wherever it is I mean
he can play in this league he's a he's
an incredible football players oh that's
some really good stuff here and it's
really fun being at watch him go out
there and do his thing
I just love stories of people who try so
hard
won't give up and make it and and and
are in the NFL and again this is a
crucial role that he's playing this week
there's no doubt about that
right oh yeah I mean Jackson is an
incredible football player using these
metal due this year not just on the
ground but through the air as well and I
don't have a ton of respect for his game
and I mean it's hard to ask anyone to
truly emulate what he's doing for a
defense but obviously you have to have a
plan for that you know it's gonna be it
seemed a great challenge for even Spano
they're excited talking at the fiftieth
Monday Cooper Cup Rams wide receiver a
few more minutes left with him before he
we sent him back to the rest of his
practicing for Monday Night Football
have you seen Brandon cooks is he back
in the mix for this game do you think
we're here in practicing and it's been
it's been really good I mean just what
he brings to this team outside of even
on the field with the leaders like
leader that he is the Christi add your
guys coming in to work and just raises
the games everyone around them so great
to have him back together he's doing
well ok and what about Robert woods I
know he's been out with a attending to
personal matters do you do you think we
might see him Monday night Cooper
praying for him you know we were just
going to kind of move forward prepare
for for Monday and work it out ok and
and have have we found I guess in a way
a newfound focus on the run game with
Gurley 25 carries for him was the most
in over a year it's only the seventh
time that we've seen him carry the ball
in that regard and and obviously if he
gets going your guys are a totally more
difficult team to deal with and it would
be also helpful to maybe keep Lamar off
the field I'm wondering what you can
tell Rams fans and all of us about the
running attack that we saw with a newly
revamped offensive line on Sunday night
yeah well shoot I mean that was
incredible by those guys and being able
to get the ranking like that coming off
of having lost the fuel alignment and
seeing those guys step up and tottering
the way he did Malcolm I know it's just
and it's funny to receive I mean you
start walking downfield and you know
your running backs flying past ten yards
down the field you love that and I
really be able to get things going some
good momentum
good rhythm to the offense when you can
get that ground getting going like that
so it's obviously obviously something
that's important to us at the end of the
day you know whatever it takes to win a
game is what we're going to do you step
on the field Sunday Monday Thursday
where does the game plan should fit to
whatever it takes to win the game and
that's the mentality we take so whatever
it whatever is going to be on Monday
that's going to be working for us this
could be efficient you know we're gonna
stick to it and you know make place
before I let you go Cooper you you and
Jared Golf used to be roommates correct
okay so you are not you are not
cohabitating any longer is what your
your point right there been three years
now I'm married and have a baby okay so
you know we're that would not never not
fly so we're we know we no longer would
would not fly what do you mean is Jared
not his babysitting skills would not
either way you know that's something
that you know he wants that to deal with
has come home and have a baby crying I
don't know something that we wants to
deal with okay it's just not having your
own space so I think it goes okay so how
old is your baby
Coover year and a half year and a half
boy or a girl a boy when what's his name
his name is Cooper James and Cubs the
second name
okay so he's just he's just another
Cooper Cup is what you're saying I mean
I don't mean that obviously very special
but he's not junior he's not the second
he's just Cooper Cup
houses hands at one-and-a-half the
bottle it's tough to get the bottle out
of the hands or he's got some grippers
on him I'm not sure that's the receivers
can be their own okay is he is he aware
that a certain sports talk radio host
and sports host needs a big huge ass
game out of his dad for fantasy with the
fantasy team on the lines aware of that
I mean just I don't know how up if
you'll totally understand my needs
Cooper I'm sure he has his own but
alright I'll just break down I'll just
break down I got a have a Cooper I got a
have I got a habit okay okay will you
please I mean seriously like in the
huddle
if Goff calls like another running play
for Todd Gurley like a 25th running play
got it you said you got to interject it
it's that point no promises okay thank
you Cooper Cup appreciate the time thank
you sir really love the way you go about
your business Congrats on your baby
obviously a year and a half late and
down the line you go that's Cooper Cup
at Cooper Cup on Twitter and Instagram
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app